هل هذا يعني السلام كلا جزء من اوكرانيا
لا يزال خاضعا تحت العدوان الروسي
والهيمنه الروسيه لا بد من وقف هذه
الاعمال العدائيه التي تفضي تلقائيا الى
السلام هذا السلام يعني باننا سوف نعطي
الشعب الاوكراني ما يستحقه وهذا يعني بان
ذلك سوف يكون نهايه للنظام العالمي
والقانون العالمي اللي هو هذه نقطه ثانيه
واعتقد ان المستشار كان واضحا في ذكره
لهذا الامر في هذه اللحظه يجب ان نقول بان
بان روسيا تحاول ان تقدم جزءا من اوكرانيا
وهذه هي صفات القاده
العدائيين الذين يسعون دائما لاحتلال
اراضي دول اخرى وفي المانيا ايضا وفي
انحاء العالم يتساءلون انه انه اذا لم اذا
لم يكن ليتم تقديم هذا السلاح لما انتشر
الحرب لم انتشرت الحرب بهذه الطريقه لو
كنا قد قررنا في السابع والعشرين من
فبراير في البرلمان الالماني او في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير في انحاء اخرى من
العالم لدعم اوكرانيا لما كانت 13 مليون
لاجئ اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا ومليون منهم في
المانيا اجمالي عدد سكان في اوكرانيا هو
42 مليون نسمه لو لم ندعم اوكرانيا منذ
منذ الرابع والعشرين منذ 27 من فبراير لو
كنا قد راينا ماريوبول واماكن اخرى كلها
تقع تحت سيطره روسيا ما هي النتائج
التي سوف نلمسها من خلال هذا الدعم
العالمي الاثر والنتائج بانه لم نستطع
للاسف
احلالي السلام في اوكرانيا بسبب رغبه
روسيا في غزو في احتلالها وهذا سوف يجعل
حياتي الملايين جحيما لا بد من حمايه
المدنيين يوما تلو الاخر طالما ان روسيا
تقوم بهذه العماله الغذائيه
[تصفيق]
ان اشير الى انه عندما نتحدث عن السلام
فهل نحن نشير الى روسيا وعودتها الى ما
قبل خطوط 24 من فبراير من العام الماضي ام
نتحدث عن العام 2014 لان شبه جزيره القرم
هي قضيه تقدم مضاجع الشعب الاوكراني وهذا
سؤال قد
اساله على السيد اولا يجب ان نقول ما هو
سبب وجودنا هنا في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن وفي
ظل ظله من الاصدقاء وزملاء
كما تعلمون اننا قد اخذنا خطوات
نحو اوكرانيا
ونحن من اكبر الدول المانحه
بتعاون مع قياده
المستشار الالماني
وكنا نعمل منذ اليوم الاول بسوره الوثيقه
وكذلك السيد كوليبا كان الصوت
والوجه الذي يمثل اوكرانيا في كافه انحاء
العالم ليس فقط بالنسبه لنا بل في كافه
انحاء العالم اذ كان يقوم ببناء الزخم
والدعم
والطريقه التي عبر عنها
من نيابه عن بلاده تستحق الثناء
فلنضع الامور بكل بساطه بكل هذه القرارات
هي متروكه لاصدقائنا في اوكرانيا فهذه
بلادهم ومستقبلهم مقرراتهم وانا اتفق مع
كل ما قالته انا لينا لابد لنا ان نقلق من
مسالتين اولا
لابد لنا ان نكون قلقين
من
التبعات وان لا يغيب عن انظارنا بان هناك
دوله
معتديه
ولا يمكن للعالم ان يتوقع
اوكرانيا سوف تقوم
باتخاذ القرارات غير صعبه ما اخذت روسيا
قرارا بوقف القتال فسوف تنتهي الحرب بكل
بساطه
الى اين متجهون
سوف نستمر في دعم قرارات اوكرانيا بشان
مستقبلهم ولكن كلنا لدينا نصيب اساسي في
تامين سلام عادلا ومستمر اي بمعنى اي سلام
يجب ان يكون متسقا مع ميثاق الامم المتحده
من الضروري وليس من مصلحه اي دوله في
انحاء العالم انت انت انت تتهاون مع
النتائج التي ترى من خلالها احتلال مناطق
في دول اخرى بالقوه لانه اذا عملنا ذلك
فسوف نفتح ابواب جهنم لكافه الطغاه في
العالم اذا ما افلتت روسيا من هذا الامر
فسوف يفلت الاخرون وسوف يست الصرع ما الذي
تعنيه كلمه سلام دائم
وصلب هذا يعني بانه لابد لنا ان نضمن من
ان روسيا قد لا تقوموا بتكرار هذا الامر
بعد سنه او خمس سنوات
نضمن بان الاوكرانيا لديها القدره للدفاع
في اي في مواجهه اي هجمات الروسيه سوف
نعمل على تقديم اي مساعدات لمواجهه الغزو
الروسي
ولابد لنا ان ننظر الى المستقبل في كيفيه
تحقيق الاستقرار والامن لاوكرانيا وفي
اوروبا
اود ان اعود
الى ان النقطه التي طرحتها الى مساله
السلام الصامد
السيد كليبا ما الذي يعنيه يعنيه النصر
بالنسبه لكم وكم نحن بعيدون عن هذه النصر
لقد طرح علي هذا السؤال للمره الثالثه من
خلال وجود هنا لا اود ان اصيب المستمعين
بالملل من خلال اجابتي لكن بالنسبه لنا
فان المفهوم المختصر للانتصار هو استعادتي
كافه اراضي اوكرانيا والحفاظ على السلامه
وسياده اراضيها وتعويضات عن الاضرار التي
لحقت
ملاحقه ومحاسبه مرتكبين جرائم والاكثر
اهميه روسيا يجب ان تتغير لان
لا توجد لدي ادنى شكوكا بان هذا الامر قد
يطال دوله ما في الاتحاد الاوروبي فن او
في النيتو لكن في النهايه فقط هو السلام
المستدام الذي يجب ان يكون ممكنا بعد ان
تتوقف روسيا عن
تهديد اي دوله عبر ضفتي الاطلسي لذا لابد
لنا من ان نضمن من تغيير روسيا هناك رحله
وطريق شاق وطويل لتحقيق هذه النتيجه لكن
اذا ابقينا هدفنا الاساسي وبني نا
سياساتنا وقراراتنا
على ان هذا هو هدفنا هو تحقيق السلام عبر
ضفتين الاطلسي فان اوكرانيا هي جزء لا
يتجزا من هذه المنطقه فقد ينتهي الامر
انذاك بان روسيا لن تستطيع على ان تشكل اي
تهديد في مرحله لاحقه وبين هذه المرحله
وبلوغ تلك
بلوغ ذلك الهدف نخشى من ان تندلع حرب حربا
بطريقه ما او باخرى هذا يعيدني الى مساله
الضمانات الامنيه والحديثه عن المستقبل
والحاضر
اعتقد ان الرئيس زلنسكي كان يتحدث الى بعض
الحلفاء عن الضمانات الامنيه من حلف
النيتول
ليس فقط في عقاب نهايه الحرب بل حتى في
الفتره الحاليه فهذا ضروري لمعنويات
الجنود ومعنويات الشعب هل تعتقدون ان هذه
انها تمت امكانيه من تقديم ضمانات امنيه
في عقابي الحرب وهل تم التواصلي والاتفاق
بشانها
في اثناء وجودكم هنا
ومدى بشان برلين الضمانات الامنيه قد
اعطيت سلفا وكذلك لمولدوفا والى
الاتحاد الاوروبي لان الاتحاد العربي
يشكل
الوجه الحقيقي ولا توجد لدينا فقط لا يوجد
تضامنا فقط من قبل من الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا القرار
يترجم بان كل خطوه قد اتخذناها في هذه
العمليه تضمن
امن اوروبا وامن المستقبل
والقاسي قبل الداني يدركوا بان النيتو
لديه سياسه ابواب مفتوحه وما نقوم به هو
الان هو تقديم الدعم العسكري الذي يساعد
اوكرانيا بصوره مباشره يوميا لكن لدينا
ايضا وجهات النظر قصيره الامد ومتوسطه
الامد ليس فقط انطلاقا من 24 فبراير 2023
لكننا قررنا قبل ذلك وفي قمه البخارست
ايضا مع حلف الناتو اذ شددنا انذاك على
ضروره تقديم الدفاع لانه مساله ضروريه
للدفاع للدفاع اوكرانيا عن نفسها وتقديم
بعض الانظمه
قد طرحنا اذا ما كانت منظمه الامن
في اوروبا المتحده نعم فهي الدول
المتحده اكثر من مما سبق حتى دول مثل كذا
فستان وغيرها تقول بانها ترغب بان تعمل
معنا حتى ارمينيا تقول هي الاخرى بان
باننا نثق بكم من اجل تحقيق السلام لذا
يجب ان لا يغيب عن اذهاننا هذا الامر لانه
قد يكون هناك
كم نحتاج الى هذه المساعدات في الاشهر
القادمه لك وعلينا ان نتذكر انه من اجل
تحقيق السلام
في اوكرانيا وفي كافه ان حاله احد
الاوروبي هذه الوحده والضمانات مطلوبه
ماذا بشان الضمانات الامنيه
لقد اظهرنا في خلال هذه الفتره ومن خلال
هذا المؤتمر
مساعدات غير مسبوقه قدمت لاوكرانيا
بحيث نمنحها الادوات والاجهزه التي
والمعدات التي تحتاجها لدفاع عن نفسها
وهذه وهذا من قبيل الالتزام الدائم لان
كل ما نقدمه لاوكرانيا سوف يعود بالنفع
على اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل للدفاع عن
نفسها
وكنا نتحدث بصوره
نشطه حول ما يمكن فعله ليس فقط على المدى
القصير بل على المدى المدى الطويل بحيث في
نتحاشى اي تكرار لهذه العمليات العمليات
الغزو الروسيه
سعاده الوزير
افضل ضمانات الامنيه هي العقوبات والاسلاح
والاموال
لكن الضمان الامني الاكثر اهميه هو ان
الذي يمكن للشركاء تقديمه لاوكرانيا يتمثل
بان يتم العمل بصوره
مؤكده وغير مشروطه بانتصار اوكرانيا اذا
ما امنوا بذلك واذا ما كان هذا هو المبدا
التاسيسي لصنع سياسات فكافه الامور الاخرى
سوف تسير على خطى
واعلم اننا نؤمن بهذا الهدف
ونعلم بانه يجب ان لا نقنع الاخرين بهم
لان كافه القرارات التي تتخذ في برلين
واشنطن وفي المؤسسات الاخرى الحكوميه فهي
تعتمد على افتراض ان اوكرانيا يجب ان تفوز
في هذه الحرب
اذا اخذنا هذه الف كره فهذه قد تكون نقطه
فهد يجب ان تكون القناعه في في
مساله حربنا التي ناجح الان هل لديكم اي
شكوك في خلاف ذلك كلا
نحن نعمل مع هذه الجهه لك ان تخبرني عنهم
كلا
لا يوجد لدينا ادنى شك بشان انتصاري
اوكرانيا ولسبب بسيط واضح بصرف النظر عن
مستويات الدعم الفرق الاساسيه ان
الاوكرانيين يحاربون من اجل بلادهم من اجل
مستقبلهم من اجل
اوطانهم